aujourd'hui nous avons un collège
électoral qui a été listé et qui a été
validé par ordonnance rendue le 14
décembre 2018 par le président chargé du
tribunal de grande instance de
fort-de-france
sur cette liste qui a été validé nous
avons quand je dis nous mettre miroite
avec l'encadrement de son équipe dont je
fais partie ont organisé une assemblée
générale fixée au 30 janvier 2018
je tiens et j'insiste sur le fait que
sont membres conformément aux statuts
les membres adhérents
les membres bienfaiteurs les membres
d'honneur et les membres fondateurs dont
vous avez quatre critères de lecture
pour définir qui détient la qualité de
membre
un membre qui n'est pas un jour de ses
cotisations ne perd pas ipso facto la
qualité de membre
il reste membre sauf décision sauf
décision d'exclusion prise par le
conseil d'administration
pas de conséquences l'administrateur
provisoire qui convoque une ag ce droit
de convoquer les membres connus au sein
de l'association est
à charge pour ceux ci lors du passage ou
vote de régularisé leurs cotisations et
ceci dans le respect des statuts de
nouveaux notamment l'article 17 qui
indique que les membres pourront voter
doivent être à jour de leur cotisation
non vous avez deux niveaux de lecture
premier niveau de lecture qui détient la
qualité de membre et doit être convoquée
et insultes les convocations fait le
membre avant de voter droit justifier
d'être à jour de ses cotisations
le concert qu'il ya 80 jauzion qui
apparaissent musulmans les jours
contemporain précédant la date du 30
janvier
9 une requête a été présentée pour
demander le rajout de 90 ch était plus
de 90 noms sur la liste et de manière
fort à propos le président dans son
ordonnance qui a été rendu le 29 janvier
2019 a rappelé qui détient la qualité de
membre au regard des statuts il n'a pas
demandé
stricto sensu que ces noms soient
rachetées mais il a rappelé de façon à
ajuster la grille de lecture qui est
celle des statuts de façon à ce que tous
ceux qui peuvent justifier d'être membre
en étant adhérent en n'étant qu'un
facteur en étant fondateur ou en étant
membre d'honneur puisse être
régulièrement convoqué et ensuite avant
de passer aux urnes justifier du
paiement de leurs cotisations vont
pouvoir se rendre au vote il y aura une
vérification concernant ses 90 non une
vérification sera fait de façon à
pouvoir s'assurer ou l'infirmer si elle
existe dans ce combat de la qualité de
membre étant précisé que ce sont ceux
qui revendiquent une telle qualité qui
doivent en apporter la justification